voici les images diffusées par le site
d'information l'outsider pendant de
longues minutes un homme michel et roué
de coups par trois policiers
la scène se déroule samedi dans le
studio parisien de ce producteur de
musique
le point de départ de l'intervention
policière serait une absence de masques
mais très vite
l'opération de police prend des allures
de pugilat une grenade lacrymogène va
même être lancée à l'intérieur des
locaux l'homme frappé par les policiers
affirment aussi avoir subi les insultes
racistes à la suite de cette
intervention michel a été placé en garde
à vue pendant 48 heures mais grâce à la
présentation des images de
vidéosurveillance les poursuites à son
encontre ont finalement été abandonnées
et ce sont désormais les trois policiers
qui sont visés par une enquête ouverte
par l'igpn la police des polices
c'est d'ailleurs au siège de cette
institution qui ont été reçus michel et
son avocat de ce jeudi
ça a été tellement tellement difficile à
vivre
j'étais quand ils ont lancé lacrymogènes
j'étais au fond et c'est d'appeler mon
avocat gc a plaidé
plein de gens et j'ai même - voisins qui
entendaient may cry qui m'appelle qui me
dis qu'est ce qui se passe je suis
agressée et j'appelle la police mais
c'est la police qui est derrière c'est
du n'importe quoi
je peux même pas vous dire ce que
j'attends et c'est vrai que j'aimerais
si jamais au moins ça peut servir à ça
d'ailleurs j'aimerais que ça ne
recommence plus bien sûr pour personne
des caméras ou pas caméra ça devrait pas
arriver sont là pour nous protéger il y
en a point de tout ce sont qui font bien
leur travail avant déposé plainte compte
tenu des violences qui ont été commises
il ya également une violation de
domicile violences avec arme par
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique
donc nous nous y allons nous avons
rendez vous cette affaire montre une
nouvelle fois l'intérêt de la vidéo pour
prouver les abus lors d'une intervention
policière en plein débat sur la loi
sécurité globale adoptée cette semaine
par l'assemblée nationale ces images
suscitent un écho considérable dans
l'opinion et parmi les élus
ils sont nombreux à s'être insurgé
contre le comportement de ces policiers
et certains d'entre eux appellent à
manifester de nouveau contre cette loi
controversée malgré l'interdiction des
autorités un rassemblement est prévu ce
samedi à paris cette affaire ne faisant
que renforcer la volonté des
manifestants